what's the biggest tangible win that's
come out of this in terms of maybe
working towards cures of diseases or
management or prevention do you have
like ones that you can say like hey wow
this is really like starting to impact
people's lives either quality of life
extension of life reduction of pain or
is it still in this sort of
informational kind of understanding who
we are mode we get stories every day
about people where the information has
impacted their life like one of my
favorite stories is a guy from Seattle
who wrote and he had we'd sent out a
call to all of our customers send us
your stories and he said like I could
have had better timing he's like I just
came back from climbing Mount
Kilimanjaro and a year ago I was in a
hospital and I just assumed you know
looking back a year ago I just assumed
does one he's like old 41 year olds I
couldn't exercise and he had had nasal
probably had breathing cut problems they
thought he had post nasal drip he'd had
a bunch of surgeries and he collapsed
one day going up the stairs and and then
his sister and he goes his sister who
got 23 me and saw that she was a carrier
for cystic fibrosis and then that
prompted him to get tested and even
though his father's a pulmonologist he
found he when he got tested and he found
they actually had sort of a subclinical
case of cystic fibrosis holy cow and
with treatment he was able to then leave
and go hike Mount Kilimanjaro so it's
one of those feel-good stories we're
like we just completely changed this
guy's life right like he's suddenly like
he is the proper treatment and he's able
to really live now and I'd say we get a
lot of those stories also with the BRCA
variants so people who find that they're
high risk for breast cancer and never
would have known and wouldn't have met
traditional screening or reimbursement
guidelines because they weren't of
Jewish descent or they didn't have a
family history and and I think those are
the stories that like there's a clear
immediate benefit you know even one of
my other one of our good friends her
father died of an adverse event when he
a stroke he had a stroke they gave him
medication then he suddenly died and
they said it was an adverse event and
then she got her warfarin results and
she found that she's one of those people
who has like significant higher
sensitivity to warfarin and so I was
like well it wasn't really an adverse
event as much like they over dosed him
any blood out and so it's really useful
for her to know they killed him a little
bit yeah so so it's a safe I tried to
stop her it's like like hey that's good
that you know that you should be aware
in case you ever have this issue you're
very sensitive to this medication yeah
and so I think those have huge impacts
from a research angle there's there's a
lot of research the types of research
that I'm most excited about doing I mean
research discoveries take a long time to
manifest but part of like one of the
most interesting studies that we did
early on that didn't end up holding up
but we looked at all of the people who
have the Parkinson who have Parkinson's
disease we looked all of them who are
genetically high risk for Parkinson's
disease and then we looked at the people
who are genetically high-risk over
seventy and don't have the disease and
we started to see an association in the
gene called sgk one that looked like it
was a potential modifier so we then did
a partnership with Scripps to do the
follow up work on it
it didn't end up holding up but it was
at least like and you should expect in
research you will fail all the time and
in part like part of the culture we're
trying to do is encourage people to fail
so so it didn't work but it's the right
kind of study that we want to be doing
like we should be looking at your
genetically high risk for Alzheimer's
you're 80 years old and you're sharp is
attack like what is it that's in you
that or that what you've done in your
life or what is it that you have a
genetic modifier that has enabled you to
be like that and I think those are the
types of research projects that we're
gonna be able to do that are super
interesting and that will lead to drugs
you know therapies or prevention and
more and more I mean it has been a long
battle with Pharma of getting them to
embrace genetics again because there was
sort of an over a hangover from 99 2000
when genetics was seen as like going to
be the panacea for all drug discovery
and and now they're starting to really
see the potential